this is an explanation of the front and
back light animation matte process and
it was used the first time to my
knowledge to combine live action and
animation in saludos amigos
it was later used in 1947 to combine
stop-motion animation in a couple of
George pal Papa Tunes in this famous
example where Gene Kelly dances with
Jerry the mouse the question is always
raised how is it possible for Gene and
Jerry to have such a perfect interaction
almost as if they existed at the same
time in the same space well in the first
step of course Gene Kelly was
photographed against a live-action
background he's not matted into this
scene he's actually photographed into a
set that's art directed to look
something like an animation background
in the next step
jeans silhouette is traced frame by
frame onto paper this process is called
rotoscoping and in rotoscoping the
silhouette of Gene Kelly and any
additional background material are
copied onto animation paper a frame at a
time
registered precisely under the camera as
a color print of the live action is
projected onto it in this case about
10,000 frames of animation had to be
copied onto paper so the gene Kelly's
performance now existed in the animation
world in the next step the animation of
Jerry the mouse was created by the
traditional process beginning with a
pencil sketch again frame by frame of
the animation and this represents what's
called the cleanup sketch or the final
pencil stage of the animation hundreds
of tests each many thousands of frames
in length in some cases were required to
create the final action of the animation
that lined up and registered with Gene
Kelly that matched gene Kelly's eye line
and that matched his performance step
for step
unlike most animation which is
photographed on Tues that is two frames
per pose in this case it had to be
photographed on one's one frame per pose
to match gene Kelly's performance in the
next step when the animation was finally
approved the artist lays an animation
cell over the pencil sketch
and traces the animation figure in ink
onto a cell this ink sketch exists as a
separate plane on the transparent cell
in the next step the transparent cell is
colored from the back painted in eight
different colors in this case we're not
seeing one of the colors which are the
sometimes purple little pads on the
bottom of Jerry's feet and now the
animation frame by frame tens of
thousands of frames exist on tens of
thousands of transparent animation cells
the next question is how to composite
this image over the background now since
Jerry exists as a transparent cell we
can photograph him against any kind of
background if he were photographed
against a black background as you see
here and if that black background image
were double exposed on the optical
printer with the live-action photography
of Gene Kelly the result would be Jerry
the ghost
he's transparent in all the areas where
we don't want him to be and not a
convincing composite at all so the
question answered by this technique is
how do we keep Jerry's transparent image
from simply double exposing over the
background and the answer lies in the
nature of the opaque image painted on
the transparent cell let's say that
instead of photographing jury against
black we photographed him against a
white back light and let's say that
instead of lighting the cell from the
foreground let's say we turn that
lighting off the result is an opaque
silhouette and that opaque silhouette
can be photographed on film and that
opaque silhouette used in the optical
printer laid physically over the
background that we want to combine Jerry
with and it would look something like
this
here the silhouette matte as it's called
is by packed
or laid physically like a sandwich with
the background and the result is an
unexposed area exactly where we want
Jerry the mouse to be since it's
unexposed that means that we can in a
double exposure
take the front light exposure of Jerry
shot over black and double expose it
into the black area creating a perfect
fit like a piece of a puzzle
now these thousands of animation cells
photographed in color and in the black
and white silhouette and be combined
into a single
exactly as you see it in the dance
number and since Jerry and Jean both
existed together in the animation world
their reactions and actions can
correspond exactly there's only one
thing missing
you'll notice that jeans trousers and
shoes are casting a strong reflection in
the shiny background on which he's
standing and that reflection was
conspicuously missing from Jerry
probably in a second animation exposure
Jerry's reflection was double exposed to
single a simple double exposure no mat
necessary into the final shot and the
result is as you see it in the film